je vous le disais dans les titres il son
coiffeur disquaires chocolatier ou
vendeurs de jeux vidéo
et depuis trois semaines ils font partie
des nouveaux commerces essentielles qui
ont eu l'autorisation de rester ouverts
durant ce troisième confinement pourtant
tous ne saute pas de joie à l'idée de
continuer à accueillir leur clientèle et
pour cause la fréquentation n'est pas
forcément au rendez vous
confirmation dans ce reportage de lucas
chopin il est 11h et l'ambiance est
calme dans ce magasin de cigarettes
électroniques du centre de tours situées
entre boutiques et restaurants fermer
l'établissement peine à faire savoir à
ses clients qu'il est ouvert
je pense qu'ils se posent beaucoup de
questions ils sont un peu perdus en fait
dans toutes ces règles
on peut avoir un petit axe de
communication dublin via les réseaux
sociaux mais c'est pas si simple
un autre secteur d'activité aussi nous
permet pas de pouvoir profiter en fait
de la communication des réseaux sociaux
même problème quelques mètres plus loin
chez princesse circa dans cette mercerie
florence redoute le moment de rembourser
ses fournisseurs temps le client est
rare
la faute selon elle à des mesures mal
expliqué le gouvernement a communiqué
sur les code ape donc magasin textile
spécialisé évidemment sauf ait versé
dans lé code ape
personne ne peut deviner que derrière ça
ça recouvre mercerie aps magasin de
tissus et magasins delhaize la boutique
de la place de la résistance est très
active sur les réseaux sociaux
mais malgré ses efforts florence ne peut
se verser de salaire elle en vient même
à regretter d'être considérée comme
essentielle
ça me fend le coeur de lire mais oui
j'aurais pas perdu si j'avais été fermés
vu la mise en place du fonds de
solidarité pour les commerces dits non
essentiels qui sont fermés c'est dur à
dire mais en fait je travaille pour
gagner moins que si j'avais été fermés
florence va devoir prendre son mal en
patience avant de revoir du monde dans
les rues de tours la réouverture de tous
les commerces est attendu à la mi mai